good evening welcome to Washington i'm
shannon bream in for Brett Baier we
begin tonight with a hypothetical that
is causing some very real concern about
the president the special counsel and
the Constitution President Trump says he
has the right to pardon himself should
the Russia collusion probe make it
necessary but he says there will be no
need since he's innocent and the whole
thing is unconstitutional that's where
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts starts off tonight good evening
John Shanta good evening to you a week
from today President Trump is set to sit
down for a historic summit with the
leader of North Korea but even as he
prepares for that meeting the president
still very much has the Russia
investigation on his mind President
Trump began his 500th day in office by
igniting a firestorm of legal and
political debate diving back into the
Russia investigation in a breakfast
tweet insisting as has been stated by
numerous legal scholars I have the
absolute right to pardon myself but why
would I do that when I have done nothing
wrong in a conference called with
supporters this afternoon President
Trump doubled down on a morning tweet
that the Muller probe is totally
unconstitutional
it's a discredited disgrace it's not
even constitutional and a lot of
people's opinion in my opinion to the
pardon issue surfaced in a twenty page
letter president Trump's outside counsel
wrote to Robert Muller in January the
letter obtained by Fox News laid out
myriad reasons why Muller has no legal
standing to ask for an interview with
the president in one section attorneys
John Dowd and Jay Sekulow argued the
president could if he wished terminate
the inquiry or even exercise his power
to pardon if he so desired Democrats
rushed to say oh no he couldn't it's not
a rule of Trump it's a rule of law that
we live under in the United States of
America even back in 1974 Richard
Nixon's Justice Department made it quite
clear that Nixon could not harden
himself the same thing is true here
president Trump's current outside
counsel Rudy Giuliani says the president
likely does have the power to pardon
himself though to do so would be
political suicide
the United States pardoning himself
would just be unthinkable and it would
it would lead to probably an immediate
impeachment press secretary Sarah
Sanders today added there's no reason
for a pardon the president hasn't done
anything wrong and therefore wouldn't
need one the 20 page letter also
reignited another controversy
what role did the president really play
in drafting the initial statement from
Donald Trump jr. in response to that
June 2016 meeting with a Russian
attorney four days after that statement
was released outside counsel Jay Sekulow
said the president was not involved that
was written by Donald Trump jr. and I'm
sure with in consultation with his
lawyer later the press secretary said he
was involved but only marginally he
certainly didn't dictate but you know he
like I said keep wait and offered
suggestion like any father would do but
the January letter written by Jay
Sekulow contradicts both those
statements it informs Muller you have
received all of the notes communications
in testimony indicating that the
president dictated a short but accurate
response to the New York Times article
on behalf of his son Donald Trump jr.
Giuliani believes seculow simply
misspoke in the days after the initial
statement was released I think she was
wrong I mean this is the reason you
don't let the president testify the
January letter the president's attorneys
argued that that statement was a private
matter between the president and the New
York Times a private matter that Robert
Muller has no business sticking his nose
into Giuliani also added yesterday that
he is leaning against having the
president sit down with Robert Morris
Janet it's a bit of a whiplash I can't
keep track but currently the suggestion
is no all right John thank you very much
thanks